اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير اهلا بكم الى
نشره الرابعه من الرياض وهذه ابرز عناوين
اليوم
يمر عالمنا اليوم بتحديات وصعوبات عديده
تجعلنا امام مفترق طرق تحكم علينا وزير
الخارجيه السعوديه تسلم رئاسه القمه
العربيه ويدعو لوضع اليات جديده لمواجهه
التحديات العالميه
هذا سوريا لا يمكن ان تغيب عن اي قمه
ومع الترحيب بعوده سوريا فيصل المقداد
يؤكد للعربيه ان دمشق لا يمكن ان تغيب عن
اي قمه عربيه
بعد تبادل وفود في قطاع تجاره بين البلدين
ايران تضع خارطه الطريق للتعاملات
الاقتصاديه مع السعوديه
ومن ملفاتنا المتنوعه في الرابعه ايضا
السعوديه تحقق قفزه في قطاع السياحه وتحتل
المركز الثاني عالميا في نمو اعداد السياح
الاجانب
تزامنا مع انطلاق مهمه رواد الفضاء
السعوديين المملكه تقيم معارض عن الرحلات
الفضائيه في ثلاث مدن
حياكم الله تسلمت السعوديه اليوم رئاسه
الدوره 32 للقمه العربيه من الجزائر رئيس
الدوره السابقه رحب وزير الخارجيه الجزائر
احمد عطاف بتسلم السعوديه رئاسه الدوره
الحاليه
استسمحكم ان ادعو اخي
سمو الامير فيصل بن فرحان بن عبد الله ال
سعود وزير خارجيه المملكه العربيه
السعوديه الشقيقه
لتسلم رئاسه المجلس
متمنيا له كاملا نجاح
وتمام التوفيق في اداء مهامه
ومعربا له في ذات السياق عن دعمنا التام
لرئاسه المملكه وعن يقيننا انها ستشكل
محطه عامه
لتكريس اسس التفاعل
والتوافق والوحده في خدمه مشروعنا الجماعي
وهو مشروع حضاري بامتياز كما رحب وزير
الخارجيه الجزائري احمد عطافي مستهل
الاجتماع التحضيري لوزراء الخارجيه العرب
قبل القمه العربيه رحب بعوده سوريا الى
مقعدها في الجامعه العربيه
ترحب الجزائر ايما ترحيب
ببوادر تكريس هذا التوجه
الذي بدات تتجلى
ملامحه مع استئناف الجمهوريه العربيه
السوريه الشقيقه شغله مقعدها بمنظمتنا
والخطوات التي تم اتخاذها
لتطوير
وتقويه العلاقات العربيه السوريه
والمساهمه بشكل جماعي في حل الازمه في هذا
البلد الشقيق فضلا عن التقارب الحاصل في
العلاقات العربيه مع الجارتين تركيا
وايران
من جانبه رحب ايضا وزير الخارجيه السعوديه
الامير فيصل بن فرحان بمشاركه الوفد
السوري في دوره القمه العربيه الثانيه 32
وشدد الامير فيصل بن فرحان على ضروره
التوحد لمواجهه التحديات التي يواجهها
العالم
وانتهز هذه الفرصه للترحيب بمشاركه
الجمهوريه العربيه السوريه في اجتماعنا
اليوم اصحاب السوء والمعالي يمر عالمنا
اليوم بتحديات وصعوبات عديده تجعلنا امام
مفترق طرق تحتم علينا الوقوف صفا واحدا
وبذر المزيد من الجهد لتعزيز العمل العربي
المشترك من اجل مواجهتها وايجاد الحلول
بمناسبه لها لتصبح منطقتنا امنه مستقره
تنعم بالخير والرفاه ان منطقه العربيه
تسخر بطاقات بشريه وثروات طبيعيه تجعلنا
امام تحدي مع انفسنا يفرض علينا جميعا
التنسيق المستمر وتسخير كافه الادوات
الممكنه وتفعيل الابتكار الات عمل الجديده
نابدين خلافتنا البينيه رافضين التدخلات
والخارجيه واضعين نصب اعيننا مصالح دولنا
وشعوبنا من اجل تحقيق نهضه شامله طالما
تطلعت اليها شعوبنا
نتوقف مع هذه الصور التي وصلتنا مشاهدينا
قبل قليل والتي تظهر القائد العام للقوات
المسلحه
السودانيه الفريق اول عبد الفتاح البرهان
رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني وهو في جوله
لتفقد جنود القوات المسلحه السودانيه في
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم اذا ظهور جديد
لقائد الجيش السوداني الفريق اول عبد
الفتاح
البرهان في جوله بين قواته جوله تفقديه
لجنود القوات المسلحه السودانيه في
العاصمه الخرطوم والتي تشهد ازمه سودانيه
سودانيه بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع والتي اندلعت شراره
هذه الازمه منذ اكثر من شهر في السودان
كما تابعنا واياكم خلال الاسابيع الماضيه
وهذه صور اخرى
طبعا
اوليدات الظهور الجديد لقائد الجيش
السوداني الفريق اول عبد الفتاح البرهان
اذا من العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم كما
نشاهد في هذه الصور اذا هذا الظهور للفريق
اول عبد الفتاح البرهان قائد
القائد العام للقوات المسلحه طبعا كما
يظهر في هذه الصور بانه بالقرب طبعا من
مقر قياده طبعا القوات البريه قياده
القوات البريه السودانيه كما نشاهد في هذه
اللافته خلف البرهان في الحرس الرئيسي كما
نشاهد بالقرب طبعا من مطار العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم كنا نتابع واياكم خلال
الاسابيع الماضيه هذه المعارك السودانيه
السودانيه بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
والتي تركزت بالقرب من المطار وبالقرب من
قياده القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه
وكذلك ايضا القصر
الجمهوري هذه الصور التي
نشاهدها الان لهذا الظهور لقائد القوات
المسلحه السودانيه الفريق اول عبد الفتاح
البرهان في مقر قياده القوات البريه
السودانيه اذا كما نشاهد بين قواته في
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم والذي كما
ذكرنا قبل قليل كانت قد شهدت العاصمه
السودانيه شادا
وجدبا وشهدت معارك واسعه بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع بعد الازمه
التي نشبت بين الطرفي مجلس السياده
السوداني والمكونين العسكريين او المكونه
العسكري ايضا
القوات الدعم السريع مع الجيش السوداني
بقياده رئيس مجلس السياده والقائد العام
للقوات المسلحه السودانيه الفريق اول عبد
الفتاح البرهان والتي كما تظهر الصور
امامنا في هذه الجوله للقائد العام للقوات
المسلحه عبد الفتاح البرهان وهو بين قواته
وجنوده في مقر القياده للقوات البريه
السودانيه
نستكمل كلمات اجتماع وزراء الخارجيه العرب
في جده الامين العام لجامعه الدول العربيه
احمد ابو الغيط قال انه يتطلع لتفاعل سوري
بناء وايجابي
وارحبوا في مجلسنا بالدكتور العزيز الصديق
فيصل المقداد وزير خارجيه الجمهوريه
العربيه السوريه
واتمنى ان تكون استعاده سوريا لمقعدها
مقدمه لانهاء ازمتها
والاستعادتها لحيويتها وحضورها في العمل
العربي ان سوريا دوله لها اسهام حضاري
بارز في هذه المنطقه على مر تاريخها وهي
دوله مؤسسه مؤسسه في هذه الجامعه
واننا جميعا نتطلع لتفاعل سوري بناء
وايجابي مع هذه الحراك العربي لصالح شعبها
وتعزيزا لدورها
وحضورها
هذا وقال وزير الخارجيه السوريه فيصل
المقداد في تصريحاته للعربيه بعد الاجتماع
التحضيري لوزراء خارجيه العرب في جده قبل
القمه العربيه قال ان سوريا لا يمكن ان
تغيب عن اي قمه عربيه
نحن سنرحب باي دور ستقوم به الدول العربيه
في هذا المجال
كما جرت العاده السوريه لا يمكن ان تغيب
عن اي قمه
كما قلت لا يمكن لسوريا ان تغيب عن اي قمه
من جده ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه عبد
الرحمن العصيمي عبد الرحمن مساء الخير
مرحبا بك معي في نشاط الرابعه من الرياض
عبد الرحمن ما هي اهم الخطوط العريضه التي
تم نقاشها في اجتماع وزراء الخارجيه العرب
التحضيري قبل القمه العربيه الجمعه في جده
نعم نايف فعلا الان وزراء الخارجيه في
استراحه لتناول وجبه الغداء بدعوه من وزير
الخارجيه السعودي وبعد قليل سيعودون الى
القاعه الاستكمال اجتماعهم المغلق الذي من
المتوقع ان ينتهي تقريبا ربما قرابه
الساعه الخامسه او الخامسه والنصف مساء
بتوقيت السعوديه طبعا اذا ما اردنا ان
نعرف ملامح القمه المرتقبه يوم الجمعه بعد
غد لعل كلمه الامين العام لجامعه الدول
العربيه احمد ابو الغيط تعطي الكثير من
الرؤوس الاقلام فيما يتعلق بالبياء
بالبيان الختامي لقمه جده ابو الغيط تحدث
عن ان الصوره في المنطقه العربيه خلال
الشهور الماضيه مختلطه لكنها مطمئنه الى
شكل كبير تحدث ايضا عن الملف السوداني
وايضا نتحدث عن ملفات اخرى اليمن سوريا
ايضا الملف الليبي وقال بان هذه الازمات
تشهد حاله جمود لكن ربما هذا الجنود يشجع
على اتخاذ المزيد من الاجراءات وتحريك
المياه الراكده في عدد من الدول العربيه
التي تعاني من ازمات متتاليه ابو الغيط
ايضا اكد على اهميه الاتفاق السعودي
الايراني وايضا دور الصين في هذا الاتفاق
وربما ايضا البيان الختامي يؤكد ويشدد على
اهميه هذا التقارب السعودي الايراني
وانعكاساته على المنطقه وشاهدنا ما حدث
خلال الفتره القليله المقبله ايضا
نايف الوفد السوري كان ملفتا للانتباه من
ناحيه عدد التمثيل
وزير الخارجيه السوري حضر الاجتماع
الوزراء الخارجيه برفقه ثمانيه من اهم
المسؤولين في وزاره الخارجيه السوريه
المتوقع ان يصل الرئيس السوري بشار الاسد
برفقه وفد علي المستوى وزير الخارجيه
النائب الدائم في المتحده المستشاره بثينه
شعبان وعدد من المسؤولين في الجمهوريه
السوريه العربيه ايضا من المتوقع نايف ان
يبدا وصول القاده والملوك والزعماء العرب
بدءا من يوم غد الخميس الى
جده وحتى صباح يوم الجمعه القمه ستنعقد في
فندق الريدز كارلتون في جده مساء يوم
الجمعه حتى هذه اللحظه لم يتم تحديد
الموعد لكن غالبا ستكون بعد
ظهر يوم الجمعه ايضا نايف خلال او قبيل
اجتماع وزراء الخارجيه شهدت الاروقه هنا
عدد من الاجتماعات الاجانبيه وزير
الخارجيه السعودي التقى بوزيره الخارجيه
الليبيه بالاضافه ايضا طبعا
هناك اللقاءات طبعا نشاهد الان الاكتضاض
على المسؤولين الخارجين من القاعات
باتجاهنا طبعا
عذرا نايف على هذا الانقطاع بسبب
القدوم وخروج الصحافيين ايضا حتى
المسؤولين خاصه المبعوث السوداني قبل قليل
خرج من القاعه وتهافت عليه الصحفيين نعم
الكل يريد ان ياخذ تصريح سريع
تاخذ التصريحات ايضا معاهم حتى قبل قليل
ظهر معنا ربما على الشاشه حتى نتابعها في
نشراتنا القادمه نشكرك جزيل الشكر المراسل
العربيه عبد الرحمن العصيمي على كل هذه
المعلومات والتفاصيل من جده
اكد وزير خارجيه في مصر والسعوديه وامين
عام الجامعه العربيه خلال الاجتماع حول
السودان على هامش قمه جدا على اهميه
التوصل لوقف فوري ومستدام لاطلاق النار
حفاظا على مقدرات الشعب السوداني بالاضافه
الى اهميه التعامل مع الازمه السودانيه
باعتبارها شانا داخليا
قال وزير الخارجيه السوري فيصل المقداد
على هامشي حضوره الاجتماعات التحضيريه
للقمه العربيه التي تحتضنها السعوديه انه
التقى مع نظيره في حكومه تصريف الاعمال
اللبنانيه عبد الله بوحبيب وشددا على
ضروره عوده جميع النازحين السوريين الى
بلادهم
من القاهره انضم الينا الباحثه السياسي
الدكتور بشير عبد الفتاح دكتور بشير مرحبا
بك معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض عشرون
ملفا على اجنده قمه قاده العرب في جده يوم
الجمعه ما الاختراق او الملفات التي سيتم
اخراجها من الجمود او تحريك المياه
الراكده فيها دكتور
تحيه لك نايف ولكل مشاهدي العربيه في كل
مكان بالفعل جدول اعمال القمه العربيه
الثانيه 32 يبدو مدخما للغايه ومسخنا
بالعديد من الجراح العربيه كما تفضلت في
سؤالك عشرون ملفا تفرض نفسها بقوه على
جدول الاعمال مما يصعب ويعقد المهمه على
القاده العرب الاختراق المتوقع باعتقادي
وهو اختراق اهم هو عوده سوريا الى الجامعه
العربيه والى حاضنه العمل العربي المشترك
وهذا يعد ابرز اختراق لهذه القمه العربيه
الاختراقات الاخرى المتوقعه ربما تتصل
بالملف السوداني على سبيل المثال خاصه وان
جده استضافت قبل ايام خلت توقيع اتفاق
اعلان مبادئ ما بين طرفين المتقاتلين في
السودان من اجل وقف لاطلاق النار لاهداف
انسانيه تتعلق بتوفير ممرات لنقل
المساعدات الانسانيه واخر لنقل الافراد او
لاجلاء المدنيين صحيح ان طرفي النزاع لم
يلتزم بوقف اطلاق النار لكن يمكن التاسيس
على هذه الخطوه التي راعتها المملكه
العربيه السعوديه بالتعاون مع الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ومن ثم يمكن ان يشهد
الملف السوداني اختراقا في قادم الايام
لاسيما اذا ما استطاعت هذه القمه ان تؤسس
وتؤطر لتسويه حقيقيه تضع نهايه لهذه
الماساه المساله السوريه ايضا وعلى خلفيه
عوده سوريا الى الحاضنه العربيه والى
الجامعه يمكن ان يساعد ذلك في تسريع الخطى
من اجل انجاز الحل السياسي واخراج القوات
الاجنبيه والعوده الى المسار السياسي داخل
سوريا من خلال الانتخابات وهنالك يمكن
الحديث عن الانتقال الى المرحله التاليه
وهي اعاده الاعمار في سوريا الملف اليمني
ايضا والعراقي يمكن ان
انفراجه على خلفيه التقارب السعودي
الايراني لان هذا التقارب يعد اختراقا في
العلاقات الاقليميه من شانه ان يؤسس
لتسويات محتمله في قضايا وملفات اخرى
خلافيه ما بين ايران والدول العربيه كما
هو الحال في العراق وسوريا واليمن ايضا
طيب دكتور احمد ابو الخير ذكر بان هناك
مؤشرات ايجابيه من ايران من تركيا لوقف
التدخلاتها في شؤون الدول العربيه كيف
يمكن ضمان ذلك اولا كيف يمكن لهذه القمه
ان تبني على هذه المؤشرات
وضعت يدك نايف على احد اهم التهديدات
والمخاطر التي تحيط بالدول العربيه وهو
التدخلات من قبل دول الجوار الاقليمي
العراق تركيا وايران يمارسان تدخلًا
حقيقيا في الدول العربيه ليس فقط على
الصعيد السياسي وانما على الصعيد العسكري
والامني هناك تموضع عسكري تركي وايراني في
سوريا وفي العراق هناك ايضا السياسات
المائيه المجحفه التي تتبناها تركيا حيال
كل من سوريا والعراق والتي تؤدي الى تعطيش
الدولتين والى الاضرار
بالنشاط الزراعي وانتاج الكهرباء من
الطاقه الكهرومائيه في الدولتين اعتقد ان
التقارب الذي جرى مؤخرا ما بين ايران
والمملكه العربيه السعوديه من جهه والذي
استتبع تقاربا اخر ما بين ايران ومصر على
سبيل المثال علاوه على التقارب التركي
الخليجي والتركي المصري هذا التقارب من
شانه ان يمهد السبيل لمفاوضات ما بين
الدول العربيه وكل من تركيا وايران لحلحله
الخلافات المتعلقه بالعراق وسوريين ومن ثم
وضع نهايه للتدخلات العسكريه وسياسيه في
الدولتين في هذه القمه 32 القمه العربيه
مستوى تمثيل الدول العربيه سيكون هو
الاكبر منذ اعوام طويله منذ اكثر من عقدين
تقريبا هذا وفقا للتوقعات والمؤشرات
باختصار انعكاساته على المخرجات
دائما تقوم القمم العربيه بعدد الدول
المشاركه المستوى التمثيل وبالدوريه بمعنى
تتم بشكل دوري وبانتظام وان يزيد عدد
الدول المشاركه فيها وان يرتفع مستوى
التمثيل هذه القمه تتوفر فيها كل مؤشرات
النجاح اولا القمه الماضيه كانت في
الجزائر في نوفمبر الماضي وها نحن الان
نلتقي في جده ما يعني ان الفارق الزمني
بضعه اشهر وهذا يؤكد على دوريه انعقاد
القمه وحرص الدول العربيه على الالتهام
والتفاوض والتوافق حول القضايا الخلافيه
والامور المتنوعه الامر الثاني ارتفاع
مستوى التمثيل وزياده عدد الدول المشاركه
هذا يساعد على
تحصل المخرجات التي سيتم التوصل اليها على
قدره عربيه على تحويلها الى قرارات حقيقيه
تسهم اولا في حلحله الازمات العربيه وفي
وفي تعميق اواصر التعاون ما بين الدول
العربيه على كافه المستويات خصوصا بعد
عوده سوريا اشكرك جزيل الشكر من القاهره
انضم الي البحث السياسيه دكتور بشير عبد
الفتاح شكرا يا دكتور
الرابعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل ايضا
نمون ربعي تاريخي نحو ثمانيه ملايين
ثمانيه ملايين سائح اجنبي زاروا السعوديه
منذ بدايه العام الجهري
حياكم الله من جديد اعلنت ايران تبادل
السفراء الوفود الاقتصاديه من القطاع
الخاص بين طهران والرياض مؤكده وضع خارطه
طريق للتعاملات الاقتصاديه بين البلدين
وقال وزير الاقتصاد الايراني احسان قندوزي
ان المفاوضات التي اجراها مع وزير
الاقتصاد السعودي تناولت التجاره
والاستثمار والتفاعلات الدوليه منوها الى
انه اقترح خارطه طريق للتفاعلات
الاقتصاديه بين البلدين مشيرا الى ان
وزارتي الخارجيه الايرانيه والسعوديه
تتابعان بسرعه امكانيه اعاده فتح سفارتي
البلدين على المدى القريب وكذلك تفعيل
القنصليه الايرانيه في جده بعد فتره وجيزه
من افتتاح السفاره
من لندن ينضم الينا محرر الشؤون الايرانيه
في صحيفه الشرق الاوسط عادل السالمي سيد
عادل مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه من
الرياض بدايه ما الملامح المنتظره لهذه
الخارطه
الاقتصاديه بين السعوديه والايران التي
تحدث عنها وزير الاقتصاد الايراني
مرحبا نايف ومرحبا استاذه المشاهدين
في المرحله الاولى يبدو خارطه الطريق
ستركز على قضيه الحج وكذلك ايران مهتمه
ايضا في بتنشيط السياحه الدينيه لديها
مع اقتراب موسم الحج الجانب الايراني يسرع
من خطوات اعاده
افتتاح السفاره والقنصليه لتقديم الخدمات
الى الحجاج الايرانيين وكذلك يريد ان تكون
مراسم الحاج هي بدايه حقيقيه لاستئناف
المرحله الجديده من العلاقات بين السعوديه
وايران كذلك تحدث الوزير الايراني عن
امكانيه اقامه علاقات بنكيه بما يخدم
الحجاج
وهنا يشكل تحدي لهذه المرحله لانه ايران
ليس لديها علاقات مصرفيه مع البنوك
الدوليه نظرا للقيود المفروضه عليها لكن
سنرى العاديه التي يضعها باليدين للخروج
من هذه الوضع يعني انت انت متابع للشان
الايراني بشكل كبير سيد عادل واكثر
التقارير الصحفيه حتى التي تتناولها في
الشرق الاوسط ربما تركز احيانا على
المفاصل الاقتصاد الايراني والذي لا يعيش
افضل ايام بل ربما يمكن وصف الاقتصاد
الايراني اليوم بانه في وضع سيء بالمقابل
هناك نمو كبير هناك تصنيف هناك نظرا
مستقبليه للاقتصاد السعودي وصلت الى
النظره الى مستوى اي هذا تتحدث عنه طبعا
وكاله مودز الناتج المحلي السعودي تجاوز
ترليون دولار كيف ستستفيد ايران من هذا
الاقتصاد السعودي العملاق الذي بجوارها
خلال الايام القادمه لانقاذ ما يمكن
انقاده للاقتصاد الايراني
هناك نظره متفائله لدينا الناشطين
الاقتصاديين الايرانيين وهناك نظره
متشاعمه
قائله
ينظرون بامكان احياء العلاقات الاقتصاديه
بين البلدين مثل ما كان في الفتره التي
صبغت قطع العلاقات والعوده الى التجاره
الكلاسيكيه
ونموها لتصل الى نحو ثلاثه مليارات دولار
هذا فيما يتعلق الجانب الايجابي اما في
جانب
المتشائم فان المستثمرين الايرانيين
اغلبهم يربطون امكانيه استثمارهم او
مشاركتهم في الاستثمار برفع العقوبات
الاقتصاديه عن ايران اولا كذلك هم ينظرون
انه
وراسهم للكنافس مع الشركات الاجنبيه خاصه
الشركات التي تستثمر في السوق السعودي
فرص قليله جدا نظرا للتكنولوجيا التي
تستخدم الشركات الايرانيه وكذلك مستوى
التكنولوجيا التي المتقدمه التي تستخدمها
السعوديه خاصه فيما يخص الذ اصطناعي وكذلك
مشروحه لبناء مدن ذكيه الصين والتي راعت
هذا يعني ربما الاتفاق او اعاده العلاقات
بين السعوديه وايران اين ستكون من هذه
الخريطه الاقتصاديه باختصار سيد عادل
بالطبع ايران ترقب ان تكون المستفيد احد
المستفيدين الكبار من التوجه الاقتصادي
الحزام والطريق
وكذلك
ايران تريد ان تكون هي احد اعمده هذه
الاستراتيجيه بالمنطقه حيث انها تخطط
لانشاء شركات او استضافه شركات صينيه في
المنطقه لكن
اعتقد ان حظوظها للاستفاده من هذه
الاستراتيجيه الصينيه فيما يخص السعوديه
قليله جدا لدينا ايضا جانب روسي في يدخل
الى الخط
ايران ان تكون الممر الاساسي للسلع
الروسيه وبالعكس مع دول الخليج اليوم
راينا توقيع او اشراف مباشر من الرئيسين
الروسي والايراني لانشاء خط سكك حديد تمتد
من الشمال الى الجنوب ويمر عبر اذربيجان
بالتالي الصين وروسيا سيلعبان دور كبير
لكن
مدى قدره ايران للحفاظ او الاستفاده من
هذه الفرصيه على المحاكم اشكرك جزيل الشكر
من لندن انضم الينا محرر الشؤون الايرانيه
في صحيفه الشرق الاوسط عادل السالمي شكرا
جزيلا لك
الرابعه مستمره تتابعنا فيها بعد قليل
وزاره البيئه تدشر مشروعا لمسح شامل
لجينوم الشفره الوراثيه للابل
اصحاب السوء والمعالي يمر عالمنا اليوم
بتحدياتهم وصعوبات عديده تجعلنا امام
مفترق طرق تحكم علينا الوقوف صفا واحدا
وزير الخارجيه السعوديه تسلم رئاسه القمه
العربيه ويدعوا لوضع اليات جديده لمواجهه
التحديات العالميه
تنعم بالخير والرفاه انما
جرت العاده السوريه لا يمكن ان تغيب عن اي
قمه
ومع الترحيب بعوده سوريا وزير خارجيه
سوريا يؤكد للعربيه ان دمشق لا يمكن ان
تغيب عن اي قمه عربيه
بعد تبادل وفود في قطاع التجاره بين
البلدين ايران تضع خارطه طريق للتعاملات
الاقتصاديه مع السعوديه
السعوديه تحقق قفزه في قطاع السياحه
وتحتلوا المركز الثاني عالميا في نمو
اعداد السياح الاجانب
قفزه كبيره حققتها السعوديه في قطاع
السياحه خلال العام 2022 حيث كشف تقرير
صادر عن منظمه السياحه العالميه ان
السعوديه تقدمت 12 مركزا في ترتيب الدول
الاكثر استقبالا للسياح الدوليين لتصل
مشاهدينا الى المركز الثالث عشر في العام
2022 وذلك بعد ان كانت تحت المركز الخامس
والعشرين عام 2019 لكن كيف هذا التقدم هذا
المركز المتقدم الذي وصلت له السعوديه
مشاهدينا جاء انعكاسا لعدد السياح
الدوليين القادمين الى البلاد خلال عام
2022 والذي اقترب من حاجز 17 مليون اما
فيما يخص مؤشر ايرادات السياحه الدوليه
تقدمت ايضا السعوديه سته عشر مركزا وبهذا
وصلت السعوديه على المركز الحادي عشر عام
مقارنه بالمركز السابع والعشرين عام 2019
على مستوى العالم وذلك بالطبع وفقا لتقرير
منظمات السياحه العالميه الذي تطرق ايضا
الى مؤشرات السياحه خلال الربع الاول من
العام الحالي حيث كشف مشاهدينا ان عدد
السياح الدوليين الذين استقبلتهم السعوديه
خلال هذه المده بلغ نحو سبعه ملايين
وثمانمائه الف سائح دولي رقم لافت
مشاهدينا فهو يمثل اعلى اداء ربعي تاريخيا
لتحقق نموا بنسبه 64% مقارنه بذات الفتره
من العام 2019 وبذلك تكون السعوديه استحقت
ان تصل الى المركز الثاني بين قائمه الدول
الاكثر نموا على مستوى العالم خلال الفتره
وفقا ايضا لاحدث البيانات الوارده للمنظمه
من الدول هذا التقدم الكبير ارجعه وزير
السياحه السعودي احمد الخطيب الى اسباب
كثيره لكن ربما من ابرزها مشاهدينا تطوير
التاشيرات تسهيل اجراءاتها ايضا الى جانب
جهود الترويج في الدول المستهدفه وتنوع
الخيارات الوجهات السياحيه ايضا بالسعوديه
والتي كانت من اسباب تحقيق هذه الانجازات
[موسيقى]
معي هنا في الاستوديو وكيل وزاره السياحه
المكلف للبيانات ودعم القرار المهندس حسن
معتوق جنه مهندس حسن حياك الله
الرياض اليوم نتكلم على تقريبا حوالي
ثمانيه ملايين سائح قدموا الى المملكه
العربيه السعوديه انا قبل سنه تقريبا
استضفتك في نفس الطاوله في نفس النشره في
ذات المكان اريد ان تقارن بين العامل
الماضي وبين اليوم اين كنتم واين وصلتم
جميل شكرا لك اخوي نايف على الاستضافه
بدايه نبارك
للمملكه بقياده مولاي خادم الحرمين
الشريفين اسمو سيدي ولي العهد الانجاز
الكبير في التقارير التي اعلنتها يوم امس
من منظمه السياحه العالميه وما كان هذا
ليتحقق لولا الدعم الكبير نلقاه في قطاع
السياحه من القياده يده الله
قبل سنه كان
في شهر ابريل او مايو تقريبا رفعت
الاجراءات الاحترازيه المتعلقه بجائحه
كورونا وبدا العالم يتكلم عن التعافي من
الجائحه خاصه فيما يتعلق فيها السياح
الدوليه حققنا مكاسب كبيره اثناء الجائحه
في دعم السياحه المحليه وكسب ثقه السائح
المحلي لكن جاء الدور
لنركز على السياحه الوافده بدانا اول ما
رفعت قيود السفر في نهايه ربع الاول من
العام الماضي في دعم جهود تعافي قطاع
السياحه الوافده كان عندنا تركيز كبير على
الاسواق الاقليميه الدول الخليج الشرق
الاوسط وشمال افريقيا وعملنا على عده
مسارات لدعم جهود هذا التعافي منها تسهيل
الاجراءات الخاصه بالتاشيره ويمكن ابرزها
واتاحه التاشيره السياحيه لمقيمي دول
الخليج مواءمه المنتجات لاذواق هذه
الشريحه من السياح كذلك كان هناك عمل كبير
على الترويج في هذه الاسواق والاستفاده من
كونها قريبه برا وج
العمره او الحجم ونتكلم عن العمره اللي
كانت في رمضان نتكلم عن الوجهات السياحيه
الاخرى في السعوديه جميل طبعا
7.8 مليون الجدير بالذكر طبعا هي هذه فتره
اول ثلاثه اشهر من هذه السنه هو نسبه نمو
64% مقارنه بعام 2019 وهو ثاني اعلى نسبه
نبوه عالميا حسب تقرير المنظمه اللي صدر
هذا الاسبوع كان هناك نمو كبير حوالي 581%
في القادمين لغرض العطلات
وكان هذا اكبر الاغراض نموا كان عندنا نمو
كبير في القادمين الى الاحساء احسن من
400% كان عندنا نمو اكثر حوالي 247% في
القادمين الى جده كان عندنا نمو حوالي 20
25% القادمين الى الرياض فكان في نمو في
كافه الوجهات لكن كان في نمو كبير في
المنطقه الشرقيه الدمام والحبر والاحساء
وكذلك في جده طبعا هذا بلا شك فرصه انه
هناك مقومات سياحيه في هذه الوجهات وهي
دعوه للمستثمرين والقطاع الخاص
بالاستغلالها اشكرك جزيل الشكر ما تبقى
لدي الكثير من الوقت اذا عندك شيء اخير
تفضل يمكن فقط
باختصار الشديد اللي اعلن يوم امس انه
تحسن ترتيب المملكه في السياحه الوافده
المركز 11 على 13 عالميا في عدد السياح
هذه قفزه كبيره جدا ما كانت لتكون لولا
الجهود الكبيره والدعم التي تلقاه هذا
القطاع ونحن منطلقين ان شاء الله نحو
مستهدفاتنا في عام 2030 اخيرا سائح ولا لا
لسه طبعا المئه مليون هي 45 محليه
وتجاوزناها ويتم الان دراستها وخمسه
وخمسين من الخارج وصلنا 16 ونص مليون
العام الماضي وماضيني ان شاء الله في
الوصول الى 55 مليون سائح في عام 203
بالتوفيق ان شاء الله شكرا جزيلا لك كان
معي هنا في الاستوديو وزاره السياحه
المكلف البيانات ودعم القرار المهندس حسن
معتوه جنه شكرا
في العاصمه السعودية رياضه تطلق اليوم
الهيئه الوطنيه للامن السيبراني برنامج
التوعيه بالامن السيبراني امن يهدف
البرنامج الى تعزيز قيم المحافظه على
الامن الوطني فضلا عن رفع مستوى الوعي
بالامن السيبراني كما يضم خمسه مسارات وهي
المعارضه التوعويه والتي تستهدف اكثر من
350,000 زائر من مختلف شرائح المجتمع
والمحاضرات الافتراضيه وغيرها
اعلنت الهيئه السعوديه للفضاء عن اطلاق
معارض السعوديه نحو الفضاله التي تقام
بالتزامن مع انطلاق المهمه العلميه لرواد
الفضاء السعوديين في محطه الفضاء الدوليه
يوم الحادي والعشرين من مايو الجاي وستقام
المعارض في ثلاث مدن هي الرياض وجده
والظهران في الفتره ما بين الحادي
والعشرين من مايو وحتى الثاني من مايو
المقبل من يونيو المقبل واوضح حتى الهيئه
ان المعارضه تسعى لتقديم فرص فريده
لاستكشاف قطاع الفضاء والتعرف على الرحلات
الفضائيه وتاريخها ورفع مستوى الاهتمام
بالفضاء وعلومه
[موسيقى]
وزاره البيئه والمياه والزراعه مشروع
الماسح الشامل لجنوب الشفره الوراثيه
للابل احد مشاريع مختبر الجنوب التابع
للبرنامج الوطني لتطوير قطاع الثروه
الحيوانيه والسمكيه يعد المشروع الاول من
نوعه على مستوى العالم في تصميم شفره
وراثيه خاصه بالابل تم الحصول على نحو 66
الف علامه وراثيه اضافه الى كامل الشفره
الوراثيه لعدد 325 عينه من مختلف المناطق
للتصميم الشفره الوراثيه وتسعى الوزاره من
خلاله الى حفظ السلالات ذات الكفاءه
الانتاجيه العاليه وضيفيه عبر شريحه مصممه
تقنيا تحتوي على ملايين البصمات الوراثيه
حيث تمكن من قياس الاختلاف الوراثي وكذلك
تحديد العلامات الوراثيه ما يسهم في تطوير
قاعده بيانات وراثيه وطنيه للابل المحليه
وتسجيل السلالات المحليه دوليا
من الرياض انضم الينا وكيل وزاره البيئه
والمياه والزراعه للزراعه المهندس احمد
العياده مهندس احمد حياك الله معي في نشاط
الرابعه من الرياض بدايه ما الذي يمكن ان
نعرفه عن هذا المشروع
المشروع هذا يعتبر احد المنجزات اللي
تقدمها حكومه المملكه العربيه السعوديه
الى المساهمه في الامن الغذائي وكذلك
تطوير الناتج المحلي بالعديد من الادوات
ويعتبر يعني منجز رئيسي خصوصا باهتمام
الحكومه المملكه العربيه السعوديه حكومه
سمو للعهد في الاهتمام الكبير في الابل
وكذلك الاستفاده المثلى من الابل في
المساهمه الامن الغذائي على وطن على
الاستفاده منها في جميع المناحي التي ممكن
انها تقدم اضافه للناتج القومي للمملكه
العربيه السعوديه كيف يتم الاستفاده من
الدكتور
المشروع هذا سيعمل على تحديد الصفات
الوراثيه للابل من خلال المواليد الجديده
لكي لابسطها بشكل واضح سيكون يحدد
المواليد هل هي ستكون مخصصه للسباق خليتكم
مخصصه للحليب هل هي مخصصه للحوم ولذلك
لزياده الكفاء الانتاجيه لتلك الانتاج من
الابل علاوه على ان تصميم الوراد
تصميم الوراثي سيؤسس قاعده بيانات وطنيه
وراثيه مرجعيه للابل المحليه لتسجيل
السلالات وكذلك وضع الخطط المستقبليه لها
علاوه على ان تطوير تحاليل الجين ومن
الابل للتمييز بين السلالات المحليه يؤدي
الى مستهدفات هذه السلالات بالنسبه من
خلال تحديد الاختلافات الوراثيه على اسس
البصمه الوراثيه وكما ذكر في
التقرير ولله الحمد تجاوزنا اكثر من خمسه
وستين الف علامه وراثيه التي تتيح لنا
تحديد تلك الانواع والاجناس بما يخدم
المستهدفه الرئيسيه وفي نفس الوقت العمل
هذا العمل الوطني تشارك فيه ولله الحمد
شركائنا في الابل مثل نادي الابل والاتحاد
السعودي للهجن ومدينه الملك عبد العزيز
وتم كذلك بمشاركه بعض الجهات المختبرات
الدوليه المتخصصه على بعض الشركات
العالميه المتخصصه التي ادت الى هذا
المنجز والسكون بمشيئه الله على مفارقه
تساهم في زياده الاقتصاديه للابل في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه القاعده قاعده
البيانات الوراثيه الوطنيه للابل المحليه
وتسجيلها يعني دوليا ابي اسال عن هذه
الخطوه اولا كيف ستكتمل وش اللي راح
تستفيدونه ايضا من هذه القاعده
القاعده ستمكننا من ان نبني جميع جميع
القرارات الرئيسيه المستقبليه في المجال
الاقتصادي بناء هذه القاعده وستكون قاعده
قاعده اساسيه متراكمه عليها من خلال ادخال
البيانات التراكميه والتي ستؤدي في نهايه
المطاف الى الاستقلال الامثل لتلك المورد
الرئيس عطني مثال مهندس احمد على على
هالموضوع على اتخاذ قرار بناء على هذه
القاعده قاعده البيانات حتى نبسط الموضوع
اكثر للمشاهد
لما ناخذ
ويحدد لنا هذه الابل كم انتاجيتها من
الحليب بعد فتره من الزمن كذلك هل هو
الافضل استغلال هذه الحليب ام للا
بل تلاوه على تطوير الجينات مستقبليه
مستقبلا بناء على هالقواعد على حجم
المعلومات بحيث يكون الانتخاب مبني على
تلك الاسس العلميه انا اوضحها الان
الابقار تكرمون يكرم السامعين متطور جينيا
بالكامل على مستوى العالم لكن الابل الان
بدا هذا التطور من انطلاق هذه المسحه
الشامل ممتاز طيب انتوا حصلتوا على 66 الف
علامه وراثيه كم المستهدف عندكم تحصلوا
على كم علامه وراثيه مهندس
العلامات الوراثيه مربوطه في المستهدفات
اللي لنا الان الع
لامات كافيه لكي نحدد لنا ما هي نوع وصفه
الابل المرغوبه للمستهلك يعني ويكون
الصوره اكثر وضوحا هناك مستثمرين مقبلين
على الدخول في مجال تربيه الابل في مجال
اللحوم سوف يكون القرار الاقتصادي اسهل
لديهم من خلال تقنيه المسح الشامل
واضيفك علاوه على ذلك
الان لدينا بعض رجال الاعمال اتخذوا
قرارهم بناء على مورده اليهم من انها
المسح الشامل سيخدمهم في الاستغلال الامثل
للابل في مجال الحليب بالتوفيق
لوزاره البيئه والمياه والزراعه للزراعه
المهندس احمد لعياده شكرا جزيلا لك مهندس
شكرا محمد في مثل هذه الايام كان العرب
القدماء يحرثون الارض في موسم هجره الطيور
لكي تتغذى على الحشرات التفاصيل
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
كثره الربيع يجلب الذباب فالذباب يتواجد
مع الربيع والغراب يتواجد مع الجد وهل
الاولين الله يرحمهم يقولون اللهم اجعلها
سنه ذباب ولا تجعلها سنه جراد والناموس
اللغه والبعوض يتواجد في حال اعتدال
الاجواء وحول المياه الاثنه كمستنقعات
الامطار وغيرها وذكر البعوض قال له هو
الناموس يتغذى على المياه وعلى رحيق
النباتات والانثى هي التي تلسع وتنقل
الامراض وتتغذى على الدماء لانها هامه في
نضج بيوضها والحشرات وجميع الهواء مسامه
العقارب والثعابين تتواجد في اول ايام
الصيف كحال ايامنا هذه خاصه في الارض
المشتيار ابعد عن الداب
واشترته
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
والمولى سبحانه خلق هذا الكون بتناغم
وتوازن وبنسب متناسقه ان كل شيء خلقناه
بقدر وكثره الحشرات خلال هذا الوقت يتزامن
مع هجره الطيور ليش لان الطيور المهاجره
تتغذى على هذه الحشرات ولذلك اهلنا لولين
الله يرحمهم كانوا يحرثون الارض خلال هذا
الوقت حتى تتغذى عليها الطيور شكوت الى
سرب القطع اذ مررنا به فقلت ومثلي بالبكاء
جدير اسر بالقطع هل من معير جناحه لعلي
الى من قد هويته اطير
[موسيقى]
الى العناوين
اصحاب السوء والماليه يمر عالمنا اليوم
بتحديات وصعوبات عديده تجعلنا امام مفترق
طرق وزير الخارجيه السعوديه يتسلم رئاسه
القمه العربيه يدعو لوضع اليات جديده
لمواجهه التحديات العالميه
كما جرت العاده السوريه لا يمكن ان تغيب
عن اي قمه ومع الترحيب بعده سوريا وزير
خارجيه سوريا يؤكدوا للعربيه ان دمشق لا
يمكن ان تغيب عن اي قمه عربيه
بعد تبادل وفود في قطاع التجاره بين
البلدين ايران تضع خارطه الطريق للتعاملات
الاقتصاديه مع السعودي
السعوديه تحقق قفزه في قطاع السياحه تحتل
المركز الثاني عالميا في نمو اعداد السياح
الاجانب
رابعا شكرا لكرم اللطف المتابعه والقاكم
يوم غد في رعايه الله
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات